this is what me and Becca found after
just three hours of shelling at Ko Costa
holy mackerel we I mean we could have
filled gunny sacks full of these things
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right well here we are in Florida
where sanibel island we're going shell
yeah no wake zone and we're going to go
again go to an island oceans by both the
ocean that is absolute
yo
okay dump hold on buddy
now careful this this island has a
history of piracy okay
you see right here don't get wet I want
to get Nathan is mommy
Nathan you want to go yeah
Shelley here water shoes what down there
your bludgeon okay yeah Becca take this
up I'm sure this is only look at that
there's a live version of what we look
at it oh you look at this you guys don't
feel right clicking these pretty girls
their lives
oh gosh my croc no don't go crabs in
there snails
you're put back in the water go yeah
pirate come on ages kind of comforting
aim although that's how we roll in a
sandwich Nathan you want me to pick you
up oh sorry beautiful area
we sure did
well decade you're going to go eight
crazy the problem for you is going to be
choosen and without which hundred pounds
to bring back hey Becca oh that's
gorgeous
nicely done that is way cool
oh here you you want to make a puppet
call me if you want to keep it why don't
you put it by my foot block okay oh
[Applause]
[Music]
that's gorgeous
oh nice well here why don't you photos I
just heard there's tons of them well hey
you still live having a rough day
hey Tom you want to be a puffer fish
check it out I found a puffer fish
good luck he's alive look do you feel
hope we can let him go maybe
I like that see him hug Baker yeah I
don't know he's not feeling too well he
he was on the beach he washed up he's
not doing so but lo he's trying yeah I'm
doing a lot of things get washed up is a
good overall score me too look I'm like
this is crap in there
Oh put it right there man I'm out
oh yeah it's late day will give you
doing squats with the 35 pound collar in
the back oh it looks gold color goodness
this is insane I mean there are so many
amazing shells here it's like you don't
know where to begin look at that like Oh
[Applause]
please amazing shelf and they're just
everywhere I'm probably oh wait we're
we're here well that's a nice Eric see
that step that's a scallop but there are
sharks teeth around here we look
carefully it's your feel okay hmm
[Applause]
oh my goodness look at this it's a
beautiful one but it's still alive oh oh
oh that is gorgeous there's so many of
them look at this I can't bend over and
pick them all up look the sand dollar
the ones I'm passing up
[Music]
yeah there is a crab trap here Lee did
you go see you look at this thing some
digging beauties in here
this is a blue crap we got I know how to
deal with you
yeah they've been in there so long they
killed and ate the other crab that's
what will happen with these Duff these
crab traps is the crabs will die and
they'll act as bait for new crabs and
they'll die and they'll activate as new
prefer new crabs and they'll keep
killing all you got to pick them up and
check them
Oh
[Music]
what does that go to balance cool
if I go here's mother
okay these guys are everywhere look at
this see there's all I mean is
everywhere
filthy feet and there's more if you keep
and there's a live way
you find a big one there's this buddy I
said you're going to put it on the
backpack
Perley crab look at these in a hermit
crab he'll go back in the water hermit
crab
- yeah here
[Applause]
I have picked up shells on beaches all
over the world on many different
continents and I've never seen anything
like this it's amazing
the size of volume the breasts the types
of shells
[Applause]
stuff like this just laying around
amazing self hi baby hi Nathan
did you have fun with Daddy one day
people like this one
it hey did you want to go home
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
see that Tommy dolphin start out the top
of their head little Nathan bath down
[Music]
just one bag underneath and flip flop
what a fabulous trip some of the best
shelling in our entire life
and special thanks out to fish skinner
charters who who took us out there we
had a great time and just found amazing
shells so anyway if you liked this video
don't forget to subscribe to the outdoor
boys youtube channel we put out new
videos all the time